The cinema of the seventies really started in
1967 with the release of Bonnie and Clyde.
We wrapped banks.
[Inaudible].
One could argue that we can separate Hollywood into two eras the era before
Bonnie and Clyde, and to be era after Bonnie and Clyde,
Bonnie and Clyde is one of the most revolutionary and groundbreaking movies ever
made it introduced film language,
never before seen in American cinema and push the boundaries for what Hollywood
was capable of.
The film tells the story of Bonnie and Clyde two Outlaws robbing banks during
the great depression through its daring style,
its French inspired script and its commentary on both the past and the present
Bonnie and Clyde laid the groundwork for the future and carved out a space in
Hollywood for the experimental and genre bending films of the 1970s.
So let's analyze the opening scene to understand the film staring into
innovative style.
The film opens with an extreme closeup on a pair of luscious lips already
suggesting that sexuality will play an important role in the film throughout the
scene. The camera tracks Bonnie closely.
It's a very empathizing way to film the character.
The cuts continue following her movement, but they skip over time in this frame.
Bonnie just starts to stand up, but in the very next frame,
she's already standing. This happens throughout the scene, maintaining movement,
but skipping over time,
The movement is maintained. The cuts feel natural,
but the viewer still senses the unease below the surface,
extreme tracking closeups combined with spatial and temporal disruption convey
the tension felt within the character.
The camera also reinforces this tension visually by boxing the character into
frames within the frame in one shot,
she's stuck inside the bed frame and to another inside the window frame in this
shot, we get visual cues of her juvenile state from the doll and trinkets in the
background.
And it's not a coincidence that she's standing in front of a bird cage.
All these choices seem pretty bold, but the editing is so seamless.
The camera work is so precise and the use of space is so practical that the
sequence doesn't feel over the top or confusing.
It perfectly conveys that Bonnie feels trapped and uneasy with her life.
The editing choices in the opening scene feels self-explanatory for a modern
viewer,
but this style of editing was actually quite unusual for a Hollywood film at
that time.
So it's no surprise that director Arthur Penn didn't get his editing inspiration
from America.
Instead he borrowed it from a group of innovative filmmakers across the Atlantic.
Part of what makes.
Bonnie and Clyde such a pivotal film.
Was it skillful repackaging of the innovations of the French new wave for an
American audience? The new wave was a film movement,
all about breaking genre conventions.
These films introduced experimental techniques, never used in mainstream cinema,
such as discontinuous editing and imaginative, unusual narratives, journalists,
Steven Newman,
and Robert Benson admired these filmmakers and wanted to bring their innovations
to America.
So they wrote a screenplay that took the iconic American gangster story of
Bonnie and Clyde and injected it with the provocative style of the French new
wave, their initial script borrows heavily from Gianluca,
Doris breathless and Francois Truffaut's Jules.
And Jim breathless is also about a couple on the run and ends with a climactic
shootout.
It has the same editing techniques from Bonnie and Clyde preserving movement,
but distorting space and time Jules and Jim,
a similar influence on Bonnie and Clyde,
the film centers on an unconventional romance between two men and a whimsical
woman, something in an early draft of Bonnie and Clyde, Newman,
and Benson also infused their script with the relentless pace and dramatic tonal
shifts. They admired in Jules and Jim,
the initial script of Bonnie and Clyde captured what made the wave so exciting
and remains in the final film and truthful also influenced the film directly
Benson and Newman center foe and early draft of the screenplay.
And he made many suggestions that made it into the final film.
It must've been obvious to Truffaut that the script had more than enough French
influence to become an exciting and revolutionary gangster film.
So he focused on making sure the film would not be so unfamiliar to an American
audience, that it wouldn't make sense to them. Ironically,
his input streamlined the scripts that fit Hollywood norms and removed
unnecessary scenes that were meant to reflect the meandering narratives of the
French new wave. As film critic, Matthew Bernstein puts it Truffaut focused,
not on opening the film up to more playful, disparate elements,
but on unifying it to give it greater aesthetic coherence.
The opening scene is a perfect example of this idea.
Chapo added this opening scene because the script originally opened with Clyde
following Bonnie on the street. And he felt that made their meeting to abrupt.
Truffaut's addition gives us a stronger understanding of Bonnie's personal
conflict that drives the story forward. But at the same time,
Arthur Penn shot and edited the opening scene still using French techniques.
So we ended up with the best of both worlds,
a cohesive story that also has the imaginative French influence.
So by the time filming started, Penn had the difficult task of shooting,
a French inspired script while also making an American audience feel at home pen
added familiar American imagery through the film scenery like the FDR posters
and the Oakey truck of the family who lost their house to the bank.
The mother and child in this scene echo the famous migrant mother photograph
Truffaut and Arthur Penn's contributions made the film suitable for an American
audience while the French new wave influence gave it a brand new style.
The result is a groundbreaking film that pushed stylistic and narrative
boundaries while still resonating with an American audience.
The film's compromise between French influence and Americana resulted in a film
that went places. No studio backed film had ever gone in America.
The rest of the opening scene shows just how far this film went,
challenging Hollywood norms of gender, sex and violence.
When Bonnie catches Clyde trying to steal her mother's car,
she speaks the first line in the movie.
Hi Bowie. What you doing with my mama's car?
The screenwriters pick their words carefully throughout the film.
And the opening scene is no exception.
Addressing him as boy implies his youth and immaturity. In a later scene,
we find out he's impotent,
his immaturity manifest itself sexually right after he first fails to perform.
She repeats her initial name.
Ooh, are you bored?
She may label him as boyish, but that doesn't keep her from admiring his law.
Breaking a simple shot. Reverse shot tells the whole,
As the script puts it before they speak,
they have become co-conspirators Bonnie speaking to Clyde from her window evokes
the classic Romeo and Juliet scene. But in this version of the story,
she's completely naked and he's about to steal her mom's car.
They follow a similar star crossed lovers, storyline as Romeo and Juliet,
but they substitute innocent love for love,
fueled by violence and criminality throughout the film,
lawbreaking and violence substitute for sex, Bonnie seductively,
strokes clients' gun.
And after Clyde fails at having sex again,
she cuddles with the gun Bonnie and Clyde challenges,
conventional American storytelling,
and in the same way that the opening scene gives us a new unusual twist to the
classic Romeo and Juliet young lovers. The movie as a whole introduced,
drastic tonal shifting that was brand new for Hollywood. The film challenges,
expectations in a lot of ways,
including its portrayal of the great depression and its portrayal of violence.
Give me the money. What money Mr. There ain't no money here.
I think cloud was one of the first movies to portray the great depression as
kind of funny, right?
It was a bang, but we failed three weeks ago.
Their getaway chases seem ridiculous in their tiny 1930s automobiles.
And they run into humorous mishaps,
like not speaking loud enough to get anyone's attention during their robbery.
Pickup.
1967 Feels like the year where just enough time passed after the great
depression to poke fun at it.
Thanks to Bonnie and Clyde filmmakers continue to have fun with this simple
dimwitted depression era South in movies like O brother where art thou,
but the film doesn't stick to comedy.
It creates a nervous imbalance between slapstick humor and violent tragedy.
During one robbery,
the gang can't find their getaway car because their driver parked and the mishap
has played for laughs. But because of this mistake,
Clyde has to kill somebody trying to stop them.
The script describes the scene as funny and horrible at the same time in Pauline
kills review of the film.
She notes that Bonnie and Clyde was the first film to artfully put the audience
on the spot for the first time we are the butt of the joke.
We think we're clever for getting the joke right until we catch the first bullet
right in the face to make the juxtaposition between comedy and violence work.
The film had to push the boundaries for both.
Not only was it the first movie to make the great depression funny,
it was also the first to make violence, brutally realistic.
It introduced the use of squibs,
a small explosive device placed on an actor that made it look like they got hit
by a bullet. When characters get shot in the film,
we feel the impact and we see the injuries take a toll on them.
This brand new realism enhance the comedy as much as it enhanced the violence in
one shootout, the realistic and brutal violence makes it gang members,
frantic screaming that much more.
Hilarious.
Before Bonnie and Clyde movies always told their story straight,
dark comedies like Dr. Strange love had been coming out for years before Bonnie
and Clyde,
but their satirical tone remained consistent from beginning to end the
juxtapositioning and Bonnie and Clyde opened to the door for filmmakers to play
with audience expectations towards tone and violence. By 1969,
we were already seeing the effects,
the extreme violence in the wild bunch and the intense irony of Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance kid owe a lot to Bonnie and Clyde. And by the seventies,
it was in full swing Francis Coppola,
himself copied the brutal realism in Bonnie and Clyde for the godfather by also
using scripts and making the violence feel raw and intense and any modern movie
that plays with emotional expectations owes itself to the revolutionary
screenplay of Bonnie and Clyde.
Out.
When Marvin gets shot in the face simple fiction,
it feels just like the banker getting shot in the face.
Funny and horrible at the same time.
And the juxtaposition of Midwestern niceties and gruesome murder in Fargo feels
just like a gang member, flailing helplessly in the middle of a shootout.
So what's the deal. Now Carrie says triple homicide. Yeah, it looks pretty bad.
So the next time you watch a contemporary American film with drastic shifts in
tone, bold editing or audience challenging storylines,
don't forget which couples started.
At all. Thanks.
While Bonnie and Clyde did poke fun at depression era, rural America,
it also highlights the desperation. People felt during that time.
It's partially why Bonnie is willing to join,
but she has few other economic prospects as a waitress.
And if you want to learn more about this tumultuous time in history,
I'd recommend watching the two-part documentary in 1929.
It's a riveting history of the stock market crash and the great depression.
And it's only available on curiosity street, curiosity,
stream's newly expanded library has thousands of titles that will send you down
the rabbit hole on topics like art, science, and history.
And because they know that these are rapidly changing times,
CuriosityStream is offering a 40% discount off annual plans right now.
What better way to spend your quarantine days than to expand your mind?
And there's more to curiosity. Stream has partnered with Nebula,
the creator owned streaming service that I actually helped build along with a
bunch of other creators, you know, and love there.
We're posting all of our content at free, as well as creating Nebula originals,
like the ongoing series, working titles.
It's a series analyzing TV title sequences with episodes by Patrick H. Williams,
just right, and yours truly.
And nebulous subscriptions are automatically included with an annual
subscription to curiosity stream.
We hope this makes it easier to hashtag stay at home.
So if you want to try both CuriosityStream and Nebula free for 30 days,
go to curiosity, stream.com/. Now you see it and enter the promo code.
Now you see it when prompted during the signup process,
thanks to curiosity stream for sponsoring and thanks to you,
our patrons for your support. If you want to support our work directly,
join our Patriot for exclusive benefits. Thanks for watching.